23 children some as young as 8 among the
77 people rescued here after a promise
of heaven
pastors at the church had encouraged
them to wait for the second coming of
christ
and wait they did
for months
it wasn't until a local mother alerted
the police after her child didn't come
home from church for a whole week
so she actually went to the church to
see if she could bring her children back
home but she was allegedly beaten by
some of the church members who claimed
that the children were
doing some kind of
the work of
god
another student is reported to have
dropped out of medical school to take
part in the wait initially expecting
christ to come in april then that was
changed in september that's when
concerns were finally raised
by the time the police got to the church
just to see the pastor to invite him
the members of the church turned violent
and assaulted the policemen
claiming they do not have the right to
come
to this place and they do not like to
come to the church
investigators say all the members went
into the basement voluntarily and that
they found no evidence that anyone was
abused or forced to stay two pastors are
in custody sadia chowdhury sky news